so with DeSantis potentially finding
some light here and being able to gain
some ground what what's going on with
the rest of the field the rest of the
field is going after DeSantis you saw
this uh just now with Chris Christie you
know I've talked about my dark horse bet
that Chris Christie could really have a
moment in this race and I know everyone
mocks me forward talking about the
chrysosons the croissants we call it for
short but
if I were even allowed to BET
unpredicted right now predict it's not
even showing Chris Christie in the GOP
Primary betting markets I'd put a small
amount of money on it because I think he
could he could have a blip at least a
moment Christy is not going after Trump
right now he's going after
Ron DeSantis specifically over January
6th
I wasn't anywhere near Washington that
day I have nothing to do with what
happened that day obviously I didn't
enjoy seeing you know what what happened
but we've got to go forward on this
stuff we cannot be looking backwards and
be mired in the past he talked a little
bit before that about how Biden is
running for office and why he or Biden
running and why he should defeat him but
is that the way you think Republicans
should be answering that question on
January the 6th he wasn't anywhere near
Washington did he have a TV
Was he alive that day
did he see what was going on I mean
that's one of the most ridiculous
answers I've heard in this race so far
you don't have an opinion about January
6th except to say I didn't particularly
enjoy
what happened
people were killed exactly a strong
statement people were killed people were
killed that's true well one person was
killed the one person who was killed in
the political violence of that day was a
trump supporter who was killed by a
trigger-happy cop that's the part that
Chris Christie leaves out there
but it's it's a smart attack for Christy
because Christie's running a kind of a
Kamikaze campaign
where he's theoretically trying to go
after Donald Trump but he knows if he
wants to stay in long enough to go after
Trump he's got to take out Ron DeSantis
and this is the key this is probably the
biggest advantage that Trump has in 2024
which we'll get to in one second first
though I want to tell you about great
delicious meat I want to tell you about
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchors.com use promo codes if you
have not yet heard the FDA has approved
lab-grown chicken for sale
yeah meet
formed in a lab will soon be coming to a
store near you
yuck if you prefer real meat grown in a
pasture instead of a petri dish then you
need good ranchers not only do they sell
real meat from real animals but they
sell the best meat that this country has
to offer from Steakhouse quality cuts of
beef to better than organic chicken
everything good Rancher sources is from
local farms in America plus right now
you'll get 30 off with my code Knowles
Canada W Valley ass at goodranchers.com
they've got terrific products top tier
customer service you can't call the
scientists in the lab to ask about their
fake meat but good ranchers has a team
of people available for you to call and
answer all your questions real meat real
service top stuff on the market I just
absolutely love their products what are
you waiting for enjoy real meat real
service today with good ranchers
goodranchors.com use code knows for 30
bucks off any box promo code Knowles at
goodranchers.com goodranchers.com
American meat delivered right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 is central banks in
countries like China India and Australia
begin looking to transition to a digital
currency the Federal Reserve has been
contemplating the same for the U.S with
a digital currency the government could
track every single purchase you make
officials could even prohibit you from
purchasing certain products or easily
freeze or seize part or all of your
money Times Like These are a great
reminder to diversify a portion of your
savings into gold you can do that with
the help of Birch gold they are who I
buy my gold from so do thousands of
other concern Savers Birch gold will
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into an IRA in Gold you don't pay a
penny out of pocket when currencies fail
gold is a safe haven how much more time
does the Dollar have protect your
savings with gold Birch gold has an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers
text Knowles to 98 98 98 get your free
info kit on gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it's
going to be nice to have some gold to
depend upon right now text Knowles
Canada wlas to 98 98 98. Christy is
going after DeSantis because if DeSantis
remains strong then none of the other
candidates are going to have a chance to
really take their shot at the cane at
Donald Trump
which means that the candidates are
going to focus their fire onto the
santis
which means Trump is going to maintain
his big league it it probably is not
going to help the the lower polling
candidates it could hurt DeSantis we've
already seen the sentences numbers go
down that is why this nomination
is set up in such a way
that Donald Trump has the overwhelming
likelihood of becoming the nominee and I
talked to many people around the country
I'm on the road constantly and they say
oh you know I just wish Trump would get
out of this thing I hope you I wish you
would drop out and some people still
love Trump by the way I don't want to
under sell that either there are a lot
of people who still love Trump they're
gung-ho they want him to have another
four years but the ones who say oh I
wish it were some other candidate maybe
DeSantis or somebody like that why won't
he just drop out the reason he won't
just drop out
is because if you were telling yourself
that Trump is not going to be the
nominee because of some prosecution or
because he is
too much of a loudmouth or something
like that you are fooling yourself you
are crazy this nomination is Trump's
nomination to lose by a country mile
I'm not saying he can't lose it I'm not
saying some other candidate can't pop up
but right now it is not even close and
the the primary is
the circumstances of them are just such
right now that
all of the incentives are for the other
candidates to take out DeSantis not
Trump now speaking of some of the other
candidates
you know
there's a candidate here who he and I go
back to college together he was at the
law school when I was in an
undergraduate and a lot of people didn't
know who he was when he announced that
he was running and I said hey
don't underestimate this guy
and some people said oh he's this guy
he's an entrepreneur he's the Andrew
Yang of 2024 GOP Primary
I said I wouldn't compare him to Andrew
yang this guy's a lot sharper he's a lot
more focused he's a lot more disciplined
a campaigner
this guy could go somewhere
a lot of people laughed you know I hate
to say I told you so
he's going somewhere Vivek ramaswamy has
just broken double digits in the
Republican primary race according to
Echelon insights which is a serious
polling firm
the poll found as I have said for a long
time that Donald Trump has a strong lead
he's got 49 support
DeSantis is only at 16 support right now
so now Trump has opened up the Gap it's
not just in the 20s anymore it's not
just 30 31 it's not 33 point gap
and then ramaswamy comes in
third
that's pretty when you think about how
many people are in the race you've got
multiple Governors you've got
Governor Nikki Haley governor ASA
Hutchinson who's kind of you know okay
whatever Governor Chris Christie you've
got a sitting U.S senator Tim Scott
you've got other candidates and then
this guy Vivek
this this Tech Pharma entrepreneur
anti-woke business guy who's got an
anti-woke asset management fund you know
he's kind of like a weirdo and he's come
out of nowhere because he's got a
message that appears to be resonating
with people
if anything goes wrong with the DeSantis
campaign DeSantis obviously a strong
number two right now
the vague has a real shot at being
bumped up to number two and then who
knows who knows what happens from there
in any case though let's say you say all
right he's in double digits but he's not
going to go the distance
again wouldn't make predictions this far
out but let's let's say that were the
case
the vague has every incentive to stay in
this race his message is resonating his
numbers are rising and every moment he
stays in gives him a better opportunity
to if he loses the nomination to become
a cabinet pick to become
of running mate even potentially to to
have more power and influence over the
GOP and potentially over the
presidential ticket in 2024 all the
incentives are there and
the the influence just keeps Rising for
him boy that was a great clip I know I
agree make sure that you get more of
them by subscribing here to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel ring the bell
we'll see you next time